[Music]
what are you doing here in Somerville
anyway honestly my mom won't say it but
we're completely broke any on this thing
that's left in our name this is creepy
old farmhouse my grandfather left us in
the middle of nowhere why'd you bring me
up here entertainment value what is that
[Music]
somehow a town that isn't anywhere near
a tectonic plate that has no fall lines
no fracking no loud music even is
shaking on a daily basis
I remember that one summer me died on
her table
I found this in my living room whoa
killer replica a replica of what a ghost
trap there hasn't been a ghost sighting
in 30 years New York in the 80s it's
like The Walking Dead
your dad never mentioned this to you
it's just my mom
my grandfather died my mom says we're
just here to pick through the Rob loves
life
when
who are you
[Music]
call it fake
[Music]
call it lock
[Music]
call it karma
[Music]
I believe that everything happens for a
reason
come on darlin
it has a connor seat
[Music]